[Music]
what is your best kisser
I'm gonna say with now Wilson all movie
that we did Cara Delevingne might be
changing her answer to that question now
check out the supermodel smooching
rumored girlfriend Ashley Benson at
London's Heathrow Airport on Tuesday
yeah it's great
Ashley kept a classic in a denim jacket
well Cara opted for a tan jacket with a
fun braided dude
earlier this month the ladies celebrated
Cara's 26th birthday at a salsa night in
Los Angeles an eyewitness told et they
were quote intimately dancing with each
other and last seen throughout the night
Ashley and Cara have both been pretty
private about their personal lives I
never came out and spoke about that that
was something that though Ashley posted
these pics of Cara back in May first
sparking romance rumors and in 2015
Guerra had this to say about her
sexuality there's so much prejudice
towards everyone's choices and who you
are I think some of the most important
thing is to start talking about stuff
like that especially since in the past
there's been so little talk I'm a role
model and I want you know people to
realize that it's okay to talk about it
and be comfortable with who you are no
matter what that means